six years ago i told clients of jim
launch that they should stop making
content because they were wasting their
time i was partially right and partially
wrong and in this video i want to break
down the shift that i've had in terms of
content marketing and its role within a
business the five phases in building a
content marketing machine and how to
focus on one of two primary objectives
with content marketing and so if you
don't know who i am my name is alex
mosey i own acquisition.com we're full
of companies right now does over 150
million dollars a year but i have
nothing to sell you i make these videos
because i hope that you use the stuff
you make a bunch of money and then you
come and join acquisition.com so we can
invest in your business that's why i do
it let's rock and roll with the phases
of content i'm going to walk through the
five phases and then i'm going to talk
about which of the objectives you're
solving for each of these and then
finally like of an out scale version all
right phase one is you make something
and you post it that's it you just gotta
post something sometime somewhere and
believe it or not a lot of you guys
haven't even done phase one which is why
i have to outline it number two is that
you post something consistently you
create a cadence or a calendar around
when you post you find a platform that
you like ideally one that you're
probably already using and you just post
again after you post it once and you say
you know what this was seven days apart
if i do this every seven days i will now
be consistent for me i just know that
there's one day a week that i do all my
marketing stuff what i do on that day
changes but it's always marketing
related but that's what's worked for me
maybe it'll work for you the third phase
you post you post reliably and you do it
on all platforms that's a massive
increase in the amount of volume that
you are posting this is when it
transitions in terms of objectives and
i'll get to the objectives in a second
phase four is that you go from posting
just even once on every platform on a
regular cadence to maximizing how much
every platform can take the short form
platforms can take sometimes five ten
posts a day like twitter or tick tock
facebook reels at this moment rules
change all the time if you have a news
feed style or you have an audience that
is pushing stuff to they tend to fatigue
faster and they don't want to get
overwhelmed with one person that's
usually where you get capped at it one
or two times a day and so what you have
to do is look at all the platforms
figure out what the max amount is that
you can publish on a platform and then
all you do is you crank the volume on
all of them at the same time that's
phase four most people never even get to
phase four and then phase five you go
from creating for all of those to
capturing and creating for example if i
wanted to have a show where everybody
called in and then i could repurpose all
that stuff across content that would be
me deliberately creating content in a
way across all those channels but not
only creating but also capturing so that
i could further enhance my reach in the
amount of volume that i created and the
big rule with volume that i have is that
there's no such thing as too long only
too boring the second rule that i have
is quality over quantity but quality
quantity wins over quality in order to
know what is quality it usually takes
reps to get good and so you will
probably do a lot in the beginning and
it will probably suck comma and that's
okay because it is a requisite for
getting good you start by sucking and
then you get better and then eventually
you suck so little you're actually good
the difference between phase one and two
and phase three four five is the
objective if you're doing phase three
four five the objective is to generate
new customers from content and it's
different than phase one and phase two
where the only reason you can do that is
just to have lead nurture just to give
you guys some sales stuff just to give
you guys some fodder and just test some
hooks those are the five phases if
you're a small business owner that costs
time and that costs money so what do you
do i actually have had this conversation
with probably half of our portfolio
companies in the last three months what
is the role of organic marketing play in
the business from concept of acquiring
customers that's why we do this though
right we do this to acquire customers if
you have other ways of getting customers
which for most of you would be manual
outbound affiliates or paid ads besides
referrals and if those are the primary
channels you do not want to take your
eye off the ball on that that's what's
paying the bills that being said the
purpose or the objective of having the
organic content is lead nurture not lead
generation so what happens is someone
comes in through an affiliate someone
comes in through a paid ad someone comes
in through a manual app on because you
had an sdr call them or they got a cold
email what do they do they look at your
social profile they look at your website
and they say is this person legit the
only litmus test you have to pass there
is that you've posted something recently
that's not [ __ ] that's really it they'll
probably consume two three four pieces
of content and say this guy or this gal
knows what they're talking about this is
recent enough that i know that they're
still in business this is a legitimate
business that's all we're trying to
accomplish here and if you do start to
have content that starts performing
better than others that gives you two
things one is it gives the sales guys
content that they can proactively feed
to the prospects and so what you should
build is a master excel sheet of your
best content of all time because there
is some content that you've made
knowingly or unknowingly that convinces
more people to buy from you on that
content sheet you'll have what are the
faqs what are the types of questions
that people ask on sales calls which
gives you great fodder for the types of
content you'll make in the future and
again you do it for one for the sales
team and two for marketing you do it for
the sales team because as soon as they
have that question they can send that as
a reply between call 1 and call 2 to
close a prospect or if they have the
question that they found out before the
call they can send it to them beforehand
increase the likelihood they close but
that's the first tangential benefit
besides nurture that making this content
helps you with the second one is that it
gives you an idea of what you can start
leading with on your paid side they're
disproportionately saving it
disproportionately sharing it when you
run paid ads you can look at your
organic content like dude i don't know
what it is people went nuts for this if
for some reason this headline or this
hook worked well you weave it into every
one of your cold emails and you can
split test it and say wow this beat our
control and so think of the the content
you're making as just low risk ways of
testing hooks and headlines to get
people to buy from you phase one and
phase two if you're in one of those
camps you don't need to do anything else
that's it that's all you gotta do if you
wanna know what it looks like to
actually use content marketing as a way
to generate leads phase three which is
your posting once a week or on some
cadence on all platforms the purpose of
phase three is learning what packaging
looks like on each of the platforms if
you've ever seen that meme that had like
tinder linkedin facebook and like
instagram platforms are all a little bit
different same person just packaged a
little differently this tweet here then
getting put into a tick tock then also
getting put into a youtube short and
then also getting put into a reel it's
the same concept the same subject matter
but we package it a little bit
differently phase fours you then say
great i feel like we finally get each of
these platforms and this [ __ ] takes
time it takes probably six months and
this is if you have means to pay for the
stuff i'll get into the cost in a second
maxing out the platforms which is phase
four number five is actively creating so
candidly right now i'm barely scratching
phase five we're actually just dialing
on phase four which is maximizing across
all platforms we're not really there yet
we're maxed out on probably half the
platforms unless you know that's what
we're doing right with three four five
you're actually making good enough
content that the platforms are serving
it to new audiences because they are
able to grow the amount of time people
spend on the platform because your stuff
is good they pay you an impressions for
providing value to their audience more
followers more likes all that stuff you
still have to have a way to convert
those people into customers and so the
way to do that is just having call to
actions for example if you're a business
doing three million dollars or more and
you're an internet business go to
acquisition.com you can fill out the
stuff for minority investment that's
what we do put that into your content
and then the rest of your time you're
just providing value you don't need to
get fancy with it you don't want to be
one of those guys who's just pitching
all the time a lot of people oversell
the small amount of demand they have so
they can never grow the audience the
more you give the more you grow the more
you take the more you shrink and when
you do it that way you never go hungry
because you always have more people
knocking on your door than you have
seating in your in your house from a
cost perspective there's time cost
there's long-term costs and there's
money cost if you start doing content as
your way of getting customers expect it
to take a long time i started making
content for acquisition.com about 18
months before we really started seeing
any kind of deal flow or growth across
the platforms if you think about this as
a long term play i still believe that
fame is the most efficient business
model all right it's one of the best
ways to arbitrage making money but it
takes time and no one's willing to wait
which then gives you a competitive
advantage because patience is one of the
ultimate advantages is that you're just
willing to do things for an unreasonably
long period of time without thinking
you're smarter than you really are a
quote from neil strauss even at phase
three it's going to be pretty much
beyond your capacity to actually create
capture edit and distribute across all
platforms you're not gonna be able to do
it on your own and so you need some
degree of leverage that leverage is
gonna come in the form of labor you're
gonna have to pay people to help you out
in the beginning the more costly way of
doing it but faster is to have vendors
so to have people who are specialists on
each of these platforms because what
they're going to do is get you up to
speed five times faster they're gonna
already know all the mistakes that
people normally make now one thing they
have to look out for for vendors and
this is especially important you know
for me is that most vendors are data
driven and what i mean by that is they
get obsessed with clicks and views and
impressions and subscribers that's good
to a degree it's okay to be satisfied
with a smaller audience that's just the
type of person that you're actually
looking to attract it's hard to make the
shift and it's really hard to ram it
down their throats because most clients
that pay them only care about those
things because they don't know what else
to measure just because it's easy to
quantify doesn't mean it's important the
values that you have the messages that
you want to get out there who you're
trying to reach will be more important
than the quantitative metrics are those
good litmus tests in terms of if nothing
you ever have hits yeah you should
probably pay attention to that but if
only one specific type of thing hits and
it's not core to who you are you got to
be able to resist that temptation
because otherwise you're going to build
this audience doing stuff you don't want
to do attracting people you don't want
to be with for us to put out the stuff
that we put out right now across all
platforms for layla and i cost about 70
000 a month that's to put out roughly
160 pieces of content a week you're like
oh my god like i know it's a lot that's
because we're trying to promote we're
using this instead of using paid ads so
if i were to just pay for the
impressions it would cost me about 2
million a month to get the impressions
that right now cost me about 70 000 a
month i have a lot of cost savings doing
it organically the lever on that though
is how good you are and that's tough and
it probably sounds weird for me to even
say this so take it the way that you
probably or hopefully know that i mean
it most people talk about stuff that
they don't have the right to talk about
just because you call yourself an expert
doesn't make it true and so the question
is how narrowly can i define the problem
that i solve so that in that tiny world
in that pond i am king you might not be
the best business person in the world
i'm not but the question is of all the
sources of information that are both
entertaining and educational is the
stuff that you put out there good enough
that people are like i will pay
attention to this person because if
you've ever struggled to give away your
services for free it's because the
biggest cost isn't your price if people
aren't willing to pay for it with their
attention then it has other costs which
is it's not worth their attention why
should this person listen to me and why
is this worth their time if you can
answer those questions in the content
that you're making in a tangible way
that their life is going to get better
as a result they'll come back and tell
their friends i'm not andy for cell i'm
not gary vee i'm not at my led i'm not
all closing in on a billion dollars plus
i'm not crank cardone well don't try and
compete with them but if you're like hey
i'm the fastest toilet fixer in this
side of tuscaloosa you might only be
competing in three guys if you have
evidence you are beyond reproach if
someone looks at you and says like hey
man your content's crap you can be like
this is how you fix toilets i'll try and
be more entertaining next time but this
is how you fix them and you have
evidence that you fix 500 toilets this
way first you're fixing toilets and then
you're talking about how you can expand
a plumbing business and then you're
talking about how you can expand a local
business and then you're talking about
marketing on whatever specific method
you use to grow your thing and then
you're talking about expanding and
enterprise then lo and behold you're a
business expert but it takes time if
you're a small business owner you can do
the first two phases just post about
stuff make sure it's valuable just to
make sure that you are a legitimate
looking business that looks like its
doors say open on it that's all we're
trying to accomplish and help the sales
guys out if you want to make content
marketing your actual lead generation
machine then you need to invest in it
the same way you invest in it for paid
marketing you're going to probably have
to have vendors you're probably over
time you learn from your vendors you're
going to bring employees in house and
you're going to teach it to them and
then you start scaling the volume up
internally and then phase 5 you go max
out mode right you start cranking out on
everything and then you start creating
stuff specifically but when you're doing
that at that phase you probably don't
need to worry about this video